so
[Music]
i remember a couple of thoughts
one was i feel sorry for the rental car
people
i remember feeling very very sad
but very calm
and then i got more and more terrified
because i knew i was gonna do it
[Music]
my name is tom satterly chief of
operations of all secure foundation
i grew up in
seymour indiana small town
had a brother and a sister older sister
and then i'm the youngest of three
parents worked hard my mom was always
going to school dad blue collar worker
always working always i think i think he
worked three shifts to pay for all of us
when i was a kid i was bullied quite a
bit it seemed like every time we would
cross town we'd go a different way just
to avoid these two kids that would
always look for us
they always seem to find us
i came to in one day when they found us
came up and it started again you know
the whole crying the name calling and
everything but my brother was in there
with one of his friends as well my
brother just knocked him out and i kind
of felt you know that like wow they
aren't
invincible you can't stop them they do
hurt
we bumped into them
a while after that
kind of unleashed and did the same thing
and so i kind of grew up hating bullies
my entire life
before i joined the military i never
i look back now and i don't remember
considering what i would do
my concept of the military was a child's
view of the military i played with
little army guys and you know would
actually set up the battlefield with the
dirt and would have the high points
looking down i mean i had a little bit
of knowledge from john wayne films and
and those era movies
there's really no consideration
no thought of what i thought of military
other than
playing military playing army and oh the
good guys always win
and then when my friend came back from
basic training one day and told me all
about and start telling the stories and
i was off to europe my mind changed you
know in a moment
he came back he had about two weeks off
before he was off to germany and uh we
were driving up to john cougar concert
he was being a recruiter for me at the
time on that drive up you know nothing
says america like john cougar and
joining the military so went to the mep
station before the concert and signed up
went to the concert had a good time and
uh went back home and told my parents
the next day that i joined the
it's
military
that's me holding that dead housing i
think it's heavy when you don't carry
for a while when you carry it every day
for your life it's like uh
i was on my
second almost third year in germany um
and a friend of mine kevin he had a
picture of his dad holding him as a baby
wearing his dad's green beret
and he's like this is my dream i'm going
to be a greenberry like my dad and i
thought man that's really cool i always
wanted to be a green beret you know just
because i saw john wayne the movie the
green brace
to have a green beret and wear it on
your head
says a lot about a person that's why
it's so coveted
to liberate the oppressed is their motto
and so they go out
taking on bullies basically i adopted
that dream you know silently on my own
adopted his dream and i thought i'm
going to make this my my career
how do i get to fort bragg how do i get
to jump school how do i get that green
beret on my head and that was my my
singular focus
there's only so many organizations that
are considered tier one and
um the unit or delta force is part of is
is one of those
and the unit it was a different mission
than the green berets where it's more
direct action
or hostage rescue
my second year in germany i think and
they had a recruiter come over when i
snuck in at the movie theater and he had
one of those slide projectors carousels
where the pictures pop up and he started
off with a picture of the planet earth
he goes this is our training area
any questions and i thought
i want that so bad
when i made it into the unit
at that time i had uh overcome
a lot of self-doubt
people were telling me through the
course that hey don't worry if you don't
get selected if you make the physical
part
don't worry if you don't get selected
you're young they'll just tell you to
come back and you get to do it again i
thought i'm never doing this again ever
i'm never doing this again it's hard
you know to finally get accepted
was a pivotal moment my life because i
again had the doubt of i'm not going to
make it i'm not good enough
so my first mission in the unit
was happened about a year and a half
after i made selection and had conducted
some training
let's start by remembering why our
troops went into somalia in the first
place
we went because only the united states
could help stop one of the great human
tragedies of this
time we went to mogadishu somalia to
try to stop a warlord muhammad pharaoh
hassan a deed from starving millions of
people to death
again another bully usually we go in at
night this time we went in the day
because that's when the meeting was and
that day
we weren't even ready everybody just
loaded up and hit the helicopters
left water behind
left our night vision behind
and just thought we'll be back in 45
minutes like always
and that ended up being the longest
sustained firefighter since vietnam
[Applause]
early on then it started to heat it up
and then one helicopter gets shot down
and i saw it falling overhead i could
hear it crash off in the distance
we just everything changed
everything changed it was now a rescue
mission
we went on foot the secondary element
went on foot to the crash site to secure
it and try to you know save lives and
recover the bodies that didn't make it
and that's when they finished it
that feeling of being trapped
and you just want to go home
like i want this to be over
and that's when you realize it's real
combat
you can't just go home
and they don't want you to go home they
want you dead right there
if you can imagine thousands of people
that want you dead it's just the most
horrifying thing you've ever been
through
i think the exact moment my complex ptsd
started was when i was sitting on the
bed in a bedroom in somalia looking out
a window
i just dropped a grenade on somebody was
crawling up on me to try to kill me
[Music]
i sat there probably 30 minutes after
that the gunfire was outside was getting
louder and louder and my teammate popped
in and
and you could hear the convoy trying to
make it to us with all the gunfire going
off and i asked him like are they going
to make it
are they going to get to us and you know
his answer was i don't know i mean turn
around left
and so that's when i figured i was gonna
die
i knew i was dead
i realized that uh
the walls the house couldn't save me
the number of ammunitions we had wasn't
gonna save me um
and nobody could get to us
so it was just a matter of time and i
think that's when
i gave up everything
i felt better
for the rest of that night i felt better
i didn't care
but i think that changed the rest of my
life that was a switch that flipped me
into the off position
[Music]
so
[Music]
it was
a year
or two after somalia where
my my first marriage and ended breaking
up she decided to leave me because i was
never home and i was not a nice person
as much anymore my empathy had gone i
had zero empathy and compassion i had a
short stint marriage after that
then my third wife
she got pregnant
it was like life completely changed then
for me i'm thinking i'm a father now i'm
a father and i got a son
and my only concern
to be honest
were the men
that i worked with the men that worked
for me and the missions that i had to go
on
home life was secondary to my work life
[Music]
when i met jen i was deep in
post-traumatic stress
i was partying really hard and i didn't
care about anything and
i drank a lot
i don't know if i drank to feel or to
numb
or if it was just a habit but at that
point of that's what we did
to where i would sit in bars and drink
by myself
and then i i knew it was wrong and i
started covering you know it's
destroying a relationship while i'm
building at the same time lying i'm not
drinking you know they know you're
drinking they hear you on the phone she
knew i was drinking
and whenever i would be called on
something the the shame or the lack of
respect or whatever
emotion i turned it into um
would lash out a lot of screaming a lot
of screaming and then that turned into
hands-on
the grabbing of the arms the control and
then the instant oh my god you know
if i remembered it
and then you have to live with that
right if they stay with you you have to
live with that
sooner rather than later that heavy
blanket of shame weighs you down
suicidal ideation picks up
i don't know 10 15 times a day i would
think about taking my own life
i'll just shoot myself i'll go off over
here to
acting those out
[Music]
the day that i almost took my life and
we were filming for
[Music]
an adventure company that you know
my special operations
warriors will train you how to wear your
kid shoot your weapon do tactics in a
building and then we'll go kill zombies
[Music]
[Music]
i was having fun i mean it was kind of
fun entertainment industry we would joke
yeah we're going to have van halen play
at our party birthday party jokes like
that you know we're going to be rock
stars and everybody want to be like us
and you know it hit me that day
like what am i doing i used to do this
for a living for real and now i'm
teaching people to have fun doing this
in it
and i felt shameful
and i kind of just thought you know well
man you're on divorce number three
you got a kid you don't know
you're doing a job that you just
realized is stupid um
you have no no more potential you know i
didn't think i had any more potential or
anything to offer
and on that two or three block drive
back
you know um
four or five people in the car and jen
was one of them
and everybody's ready to hit the bar
like normal i'm driving the car and i
pull it in the parking garage at the
hotel and they all start to pull out see
you down at the bar i'm like see at the
bar and i think i had to make a phone
call i think was what i said
she picked up on something not being
part of the tribe at the time not being
so immersed in the in the same old
routine that she noticed something
and i think she asked me if i was
alright she was leaving and uh
sure i just gotta make a phone call man
i didn't want anybody to see it
and i as soon as i was clear i pulled my
gun out and charged
and i just sat there in my thoughts for
seemed like hours
probably five or ten minutes and
i remember feeling very very sad
but very calm
and then i got more and more terrified
because i knew i was going to do it
and i knew i was going to do it
and i was afraid anybody would see it i
kept looking around
and then my phone starts vibrating and
vibrating and vibrating
and i'm not looking at it i remember
thinking you know who wants anything
from me anymore and
at some point i remember picking up the
phone like who was this person
incessantly texting me
and i picked it up and i saw you're late
there was a bunch in front of that but i
saw you late and immediately i thought
oh [ __ ] i'm supposed to be somewhere you
know i'm never late
i'm never late and i'm still wiping my
eyes i'm talking you know clearing my
weapon and put it back in my bag and i
start packing up to hurry what i'm late
for
i didn't tell her about it for a couple
of months
i don't i was embarrassed
but we sat at the bar and talked for a
long time that night and uh i think a
couple months later i laid it on her and
i don't know if she didn't believe me or
freaked out at the time i don't remember
now but she got to work and i think
started paying more attention to me
my breaking point
sadly
my wedding night
[Music]
i outdrank my headlights again and
we got in a fight on the way back
makeup case exploded i'm throwing things
around the room woke up in the morning
on the floor and i'm like
that didn't go well
and she sat on the bed and she's got the
paperwork in her hand she goes we
haven't turned this in yet
we're really not married
she was one of those moments of i'm
gonna fly home
and think about this
and to me
that was
every shameful thing i'd ever done in my
life um every
losing moment
you know every failing thing i'd ever
done rolled into one
the thought of losing someone who had
realized so much in me
[Music]
as someone who'd already been through so
much with me and i already understood so
much about me and had already given me
so much opportunity
if i can't keep that together
i don't deserve to be anywhere
she gave me another chance and monday i
signed up for anger management
that was a start and that's
that was so key for me
to
get over one thing
a little bit
and see a little hope
that i'm not always going to be this
monster
all secure foundation's mission is to
assist
and help the special operations families
overcome post-traumatic stress and
improve their relationship through
resiliency training talks that we do and
through retreats that we conduct four
times a year to help them in their
relationships
we bring them together teach them about
post-traumatic stress
and the awareness of it
probably 90 or higher of our
of our help comes through the daily
counseling that we do 365 days a year
we wanted to be one that started that
helps the family from the start because
we realized how much the family took a
part in the healing
to date all secure foundation has helped
thousands of of special operations
families
and active duty military members
people from new zealand great britain
europe france um
they keep calling and i won't turn them
away we just don't turn them away
i would like everybody out there to know
that there's always hope to never give
up and tell yourself that there's no way
out
you're not a warrior a big enough aware
that you can man your way out of
something
though we all need help in something in
our lives and it's okay to accept that
help
[Music]
you